the truth is you're going to die
we all are that's because unlike
whooping cough or strep throat death has
no cure but thanks to the latest medical
breakthroughs we're closer than ever to
finding one in fact some experts predict
that we'll be able to live up to 20%
longer over the next 100 years that
means children today might live until
they're a hundred and forty-five years
old and what about immortality well
turns out even that's not out of the
question
history is littered with unusual
attempts to defy death in 1920 for
example a Russian scientist thought that
he could prolong life by sewing a piece
of monkey testicle to a human's and even
more shockingly this idea caught on at
least 300 people underwent this
procedure ouch
anyways today the field of longevity is
far more scientific new drugs like
rapamycin for example can increase the
lifespan of mice up to 30% rapamycin
works by slowing down the growth of
certain cells that contribute to aging
and experts predict that it will likely
have a similar effect in humans adding
as much as 15 years to our current
lifespan but even if drugs like
rapamycin work there's no saying that
your heart won't suddenly give out well
before then or maybe it will be your
liver well turns out there's a fix for
that too
just print a new one in 2013 scientists
made headlines when they 3d printed the
first living kidney and by 2018 they'd
advanced the tech to the point where
they were printing human corneas from an
ink made out of stem cells at this pace
technology could soon bumps the average
global life expectancy from 72 to 86 and
the maximum possible age to somewhere
around one hundred and forty-five
and yeah you know that sounds impressive
but what if you wanted to live forever
that's exactly what projects like the
2045 initiative are trying to work out
by the year 2045 they aim to create
extraordinary human bodies that could in
theory last forever
but their goal depends on something
that's nearly impossible to acquire a
map of the human brain so far scientists
have only Maps the brain of a worm which
has about 86 billion fewer neurons than
our own and that means that it could
take generations not just decades to
transfer the human psyche to a robot but
businesses like cryo rusts are betting
that that day will come they offer to
freeze your body after you die for a
cold 36 thousand dollars or for half the
price just your head it sounds fine the
idea is that one day in the future your
brain might be thawed and transferred
into an avatar where you'll live forever
and should that day come only one
question will remain do you really want
to
you